Barack Obama
might be a little bit light in the
loafers
this is breaking news and it's not from
some tabloid and it's not from some Far
Right Kook it's from David Garrow who is
a very very serious biographer he is
biographer of Barack Obama there have
been a number of biographies written of
Obama that are cheap kind of hit jobs
that's not what this guy does this guy's
a Pulitzer prize-winning historian and
biographer he won the Pulitzer all the
way back in 1987. he is not considered a
far-right conservative by any means and
David guerro is is now working on what I
suppose will be the sort of
authoritative biography of Obama and he
has discovered that Obama wrote letters
to a girlfriend when he was at
Occidental College which is the college
he went to before he transferred to
Colombia
and he
apparently expressed his desire to do
all sorts of strange things with men
according to Garrow with Alex McNair who
is Obama's girlfriend
I think she wanted to have her role
known so when Alex showed me the letters
from Barack she redacted one paragraph
in one of them and just said it's about
homosexuality
why did Garrow start pushing why is this
coming out now I don't think it's coming
out now because it's a it's an attack on
Obama I mean I think this woman probably
still likes Obama but now we're past the
Obama presidency he's not going to lose
an election or anything and they just
want the story to come out and what Gara
realized is something that I realized
when I was reading Barack Obama's first
Memoir he wrote a couple and it's
something that you may have noticed too
when you read dreams from my Father
which is that it's a work of fiction and
Obama even admitted it was a work of
fiction he'd write about a girlfriend in
dreams from my father and the girl never
existed and he would admit she never
existed and when he got caught on this
issue this lie he said well she's a
composite she's a composite character of
different women I'd met in my life
composite characters are you telling me
your Memoir is a work of fiction and we
knew that because so much of Barack
Obama's actual biography did not line up
with reality I think this is one of the
things that fueled the the birther idea
that he wasn't really born in Hawaii or
something that wasn't just some crazy
kooky idea that a bunch of mean nasty
people thought about nowhere it's
because Barack Obama had lied about so
much of his biography the story kept
changing one of his Publishers actually
wrote on the book jacket of one of his
books that he was born in Kenya but even
let's say that was just an accident so
much of his biography in his own pen in
his own writing was fiction and so now
this biographer says okay Barack Obama
you know a little bit uh a big musical
theater fan let's say you know what does
this mean for him I have a little bit of
a different take than a lot of the
conservatives do but first when you want
to look good you don't want to just
rewrite your Memoirs and lie about your
past if you want to look good you got to
just use genucel right now go to
genucel.com Knowles that dark spot on
your face is it still bothering you what
about all those sunspots all over your
body now you can watch them disappear
safely and quickly in three quick
minutes Jenny sells dark spot luxury
system does exactly what it sounds like
by using the world famous
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector you will see the dark spots
disappear before your very eyes
instantly smoothly and luxuriously
you'll be amazed at how quick you'll see
results are 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to genucell.com Knowles
right now to order the new dark spot
treatment system today say goodbye to
those pesky dark spots tomorrow that is
geniusell.com
right now save over 70 off geniusell's
most popular package that includes this
dark spot system I love geniusell I
especially love the founder who's a
Coptic Christian from Egypt who fled
Egypt for the American dream and has a
great company with a great product go to
genucel.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s right now go to hallow.com
it is clear that the libs are giving up
their morals in any Common Sense there's
no better time to build a daily habit of
prayer and meditation building a habit
of prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the United
States it's helped many maintain a daily
prayer routine and it can help you too
download the app for free at hallow.com
Knowles you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year available
on the Hello app for brief daily
readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and
even some world-class athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using Halo to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
also you have an obligation to your God
to pray regularly don't forget that
helps you but you have an obligation
okay so make sure you go check it out
right now hello go to hello dot com
slash Knowles get an exclusive three
months free that's three months
absolutely free at hallow.com Knowles I
have a hot take on this Revelation from
Obama's biographer that he had
homosexual fantasies and wrote about
them to his girlfriend
huh
that's my hot take I had to exam
the main conservative hot take I'm
seeing is sees uh finok you know he's
lighting the loafers and I think I don't
know maybe yeah he clearly he obviously
had these fantasies and wrote about them
to his girlfriend
and and then what
people are saying haha see this proves
it ah he's a hypocrator I don't know
what
what's the guy supposed to do
I I'm just viewing this from the
perspective of a social conservative who
when asked about this issue people will
write in or they'll they'll show up to
say look I have a same-sex attraction
what am I supposed to do and the liberal
culture says well you should just
embrace it put on some leather go to
Greenwich Village you know go to a bath
house somewhere live your best life baby
go to a pride monkey box party or
something that's going to be the way to
flourishing and the social conservatives
have said
well no you should just suppress or
sublimate that desire and not indulge it
and this this is always a little bit of
a hard line because you think well easy
for you to say I mean
everybody has certain disorder desires
and affections but that one's got to be
pretty hard right I think it's very easy
for us especially those of us who are
socially conservative to say
hey look we don't have to deal with this
issue so yeah sorry we like girls so we
can you know have an ex a full
expression of our sexual desires and you
can't do that so yeah tough tough suck
it up you know okay it's very easy it's
a very hard saying I think for people
who have to deal with this so I think I
don't know what do we what do we want
the guy to do
he had these desires
he didn't I don't know it may be
indulged in them but it seems like he
didn't and then he got married and had
kids and lived a basically normal life
and he said even if he had these desires
he said no I'd rather have a family I'd
rather maybe he just said I'd rather
have a successful political career or
maybe I'd have this that or the other
thing
isn't isn't that what we want people to
do I just think if if social
conservatives pounce on these guys and
kind of mock them and then
we're not giving anyone an out so much
of this modern culture I think
the modern liberal culture that says
indulge all of your appetites
it it preys on society not giving people
an off ramp not giving people an
alternative
if someone has a
or something like that what are they
supposed to do I think this is why I
think social conservatives should speak
compassionately about them and if if
Barack Obama is expressing some shame or
some desire to cover this up according
to David Garrow he's not being given
access to a number of Barack Obama's
personal papers
probably for this reason I think I'm
good on him
good on him for feeling some compunction
about this and not wanting this fact to
come out all about it all about it man
that's the only nice thing I'll say
about Barack Obama ever so glad you
liked that clip wasn't it it was good
wasn't it make sure that you subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
ring that Bell see you next time